Tight loops, soft ringlets or ribbony spirals,...
...curly hair has a dynamic all its own.
And now, science has quantified its unique characteristics...
...with applications that far outstrip a curly coif.
Researchers at MIT and the University Pierre and Marie Curie...
...have created the world's first model of the 3-D shape of curly hair,...
...utilizing lab experimentation, existing theory and computer simulation...
...to identify the main parameters for curls.
These were then simplified into two dimensionless parameters:...
...one for curvature, the other for weight.
When factored in with length and thickness,...
...these can predict the shape of any curled strands suspended under its own weight.
How does a curl, curl?
From the bottom it seems, where the hooklike curve becomes unstable under its own weight...
...and falls out of a two-dimensional plane into a helix.
And because these dimensionless parameters are infinitely scalable,...
...they can be used to predict the curliness of anything even remotely flexible,...
...from a spool of wire to miles of oil pipeline.